années soixante dix les villes de france
se dote des premières police municipale
parce que vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
policier municipal
pas du tout à première vue il ressemble
aux policiers d'état mais ils dépendent
bel et bien des mairies la première
police municipale voit le jour à nice en
1973 le maire kresa brigade alors qu'ils
dénoncent un manque de moyens de l'état
avait demandé à être dégagés à être
soulagé de ce qu'elle peut appeler les
tâches secondaires tels que les convois
de fonds la surveillance de l'opéra de
fêtes de congrès etc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
organisé une police municipale manque
d'effectifs et de moyens aussi à
marseille en 1974
en trente ans la cité phocéenne a vu sa
population multipliée par deux le parc
automobile a triplé alors la ville
emploie des policiers municipaux
c'est une police municipale qui sera
chargé de la circulation
santos a sion une police en uniforme
reconnaissable en uniforme et dans le
mandat consistera à faire respecter les
arrêtés du maire ou de management à la
circulation
circulation à marseille et à rennes
surveillance à nice maintien de l'ordre
à saint raphaël le rôle de la police
municipale varie d'une ville à l'autre
certaines brigades sont même pointé du
doigt pour des comportements abusifs à
levallois-perret en 1984 un agent aurait
bousculé un militant cgt à l'issue d'une
réunion à l'hôtel de ville
il m'a attrapé de chaque côté des bras
et poussait puis arrivée devant
l'escalier m'a jeté
des polices disparates aux attributs
flou il faut attendre 1999 pour que la
loi détermine leur mission
principalement la sueur perlait elle
exclut l'enquète et l'interpellation de
leurs prérogatives mais autorise le port
d'armes à feu dans certains contextes
[Musique]